one second
okay welcome joe
sorry to the um gdc gambling policy
review
on class 4 gambling and the racing board
venues policy i'll just introduce you
to the rest of the panel here with
bronwyn
reed and um councillor brett
heisted councillor bronwyn reed and
steve parent your ceo and carla will
take
eminence for today so um
thank you for coming along and welcome
and if you'd just like to go ahead
that'd be fine thank you thank you very
much for um receiving submission and
letting us speak tonight
but um
if you'd like to push button are we sure
i actually need that i have to speak
quieter
um just it's in regards to what's
actually in your policy just being
enacted
rather than just roll it over we're just
asking for
some due diligence on what you've what
you're talking about inside of there
um and you know in steve's quote last
week he says if it's an issue it needs
to be reviewed and that's to be honest
all we're really asking is just a really
robust look at it
it's been a long time your last um role
was
in 2016 which was before that 2017
report which actually showed there was
no
specifically i don't want to say legal
or illegal
uh reason as to why that money is rising
um when this was first brought up as
well um just to say that your team was
incredibly open and very worked together
on this process to have a
look at that because it's been anecdotal
what's coming in from the community
there is no conclusive proof that we do
have organised crime running through our
poker machines and i'll be quite honest
i've ex i have seen some of this in the
bigger cities i wouldn't have thought
our gambling areas were
that big so it doesn't surprise me that
it sort of surprised you as well
as i said very anecdotal no actual proof
of that
but we do need to review to make sure
that that cog in the wheel of protecting
our community
and what's going on out there is an
important cog that rolls with the others
so that's all we're asking
and also um in submission for us to
review
we just asked for a little bit longer
than 10 days but if you do have a recipe
for conducting a consultation
fluently in 10 days if you'd like to
teach us that would be awesome
that's all we have to say thank you
thank you
thank you joe is there any questions for
me and the panel
have any questions for joe
i'll just back to all that your last
point joe
can i just confer with the eo about that
time frame
is there is there anything that we need
can we make it
a faster process than or a slower
process really in your case isn't it
you'd like more time to submit it just
to for us to conduct a review or
consultation you know we got 10 days
notice and i know that standard
um but logically how can you do a
community consultation
in 10 days design getting the
information analysis and then reporting
as i said if you've got a magic recipe
i'd be really interested
here we are um yeah thank you look the
the statute we operate under has minimum
periods of consultation
but that's not to say that we can't take
longer it's fair to say the gambling
venue policy review has been a little
bit formulaic in the past
uh to just comply with the statute
and the fact that we're already at the
the maximum restrictions you can have
in regard to the sinking lead policy
but that's not to say that we can't do
further
work with partners around
analyzing uh and gathering intelligence
about what's going on out there and as i
i take the point that it takes time
does that answer your question joe
yeah i look i understand process it's
it's not that simple um but yeah it's
just i suppose and this is a whole other
conversation on policies
um maybe we have a trigger it's like you
know actually we've got this one coming
up in the next six months you might want
to look at it it's just as simple as
that to
if we think some further information
needs to be gathered for you guys to
make a
wise and strong you know decision around
as i said these cogs fall into many
other cogs to keep our community
healthy safe and to limit the damage and
as i've indicated in their submission
we know there's a massive pay trade in
their province
and mdma is coming in strong as well
anecdotally
we all play a role to help strengthen
and
combat what can destroy our communities
so let's do it together
do you have any questions counselor
i just have one comment um joe i'm just
wondering that
i noticed that this there is there's no
people that
need gambling assistance that have come
forward in the ghoul district
and there is funding available for that
have you got any comment
about that it would be purely anecdotal
in a personal opinion as opposed to
fact-based
access points engagement ease of
engagement
timing of service to fit people's lives
rather than people's lives having to fit
into
service can be many of the reasons but
again i have no proof of those things
no um there's many reasons and also
being a small community for some
aspects of our lives we don't wanna we
don't want other people to see us
walking into a point
of service so that they'll may speculate
what we're doing there whether it's
yourself with the problem or whatever
might be going in um
so yeah there's some thoughts on what
might be restricting that
um and unfortunately it is a pathway
that allows and it's an addiction
pathway that's socially acceptable
and so you can spend many years waving
this off is not a problem even though
your whole family knows you haven't made
the rent last four payments
yeah thank you for that thank you for
your submission
joe it'll be um under careful
consideration
so we had um we have another person
joining us
today by zoom
euro loach
sorry oh jared jared
hello can you hear us
oh welcome jared
welcome jared thank you for submitting
today
um to the google district council
gambling review
um if you'd just like to go ahead with
your submission
be great thank you thank you
thank you i'm representing association
of new
the vast zealand of new zealand's gaming
machine societies
association asks that the sinking lab
will be replaced with current numbers
areas move to a new modern
refurbished premise to move out of the
earthquake
building and to move the land orders
demanding
unreasonable journeys
first and foremost your relocation is
should be allowed to move out of
undesirable areas such as residential
areas
and high deprivation
you may hear areas concerns about the
number of venues you have in high
deprobation areas
you